before we get to today's events let's
talk about this Ukrainian
counter-offensive that we've been
talking about for so long what do we
know is it about to get underway is it
underway what do we know about it yes
well it's been eagerly anticipated for
months now hasn't it and the ukrainians
have been managing everyone's
expectations quite quite rightly because
they've got to get this right however
what we've seen is uh General zalesny
who's the Ukrainian commander-in-chief
of all Ukrainian forces has released a
very slick uh admittalist propaganda
video
but it talks about the resolve and the
determination the Readiness of the
Ukrainian Armed Forces to do it well
it's entitled the time has come to take
back what's ours and there's always a
role for propaganda remember Churchill
in the 1940s and this is very well put
together and it's a it's a strong it's a
strong message take back what's hours
danilov who's the Ukrainian National
Security Council secretary has given an
interview only today saying the
Ukrainian camera offensive is ready it
won't be today it might not be tomorrow
but he's then talking about only a
matter of weeks so once they've said
this publicly now I think they are
setting the expectation that we we will
see something relatively soon okay let's
talk about Belgrade and what was what's
happened today uh what exactly is the
situation in that region
well it's the events are are over now
after a couple of days too uh Russian
nationalists militias
um across the border from Ukraine
essentially took over a uh a Russian
town and from the Russian authorities
ten thousand citizens were displaced and
then uh Russian troops and police
eventually uh forced them out casualties
are are disputed but the ukrainians are
saying it was nothing to do with us
these are Russian citizens this is
clearly it shows that the Russian state
has problems
um I would imagine the ukrainians aren't
unhappy to see Russians fighting
Russians uh just over the border and
will have facilitated this for the U for
the Russian militia but they won't have
they won't have taken part okay let's
talk about another region or another
city that we've been talking about for
so many months now what about the UK's
Ministry of Defense saying that it's
likely that the Wagner forces have
started their withdrawal
uh yes well it's only a day or so after
um you've got any precaution the head of
Wagner
um trumpeted that he'd finally taken
this city which is now flattened and
there's no strategic value and only a
few days later he's announcing actually
he's pulling his troops out but
interestingly in contrast with that
Ukrainian very purposeful determined
show of national Unity he's released a
video saying he lost 20 of his forces in
bakmut 10 000 troops he's admitted that
the Russian army has lost another ten
thousand so the Russians have lost a
large amount of men and material in back
Mort and and for what and pregocian has
then questioned the efficiency of the
Russian army in the war conduct of the
Russian war in in general so you've now
got the Russian leadership uh tearing
itself apart in public contrast that
with the Ukrainian messaging